there's not much to say other than you
know i always have like kept that
personal me and him and it's
you know it's something that's for him
and i well when relationships
end things change because miley cyrus is
opening up about her divorce from liam
hemsworth in a new tell-all interview
getting candid about the conflict that
drove them apart
and now we know how liam feels about it
i mean i just don't talk about it i mean
obviously people are going to photograph
it and
write what they want to write but you
know it's my personal life and i feel
like it's
just easier on everyone if we keep it
personal
let's start with miley's interview she
appeared on wednesday's howard stern
show and
explained why she thinks she and liam
eventually tied the knot
after a decade of being together on and
off the couple's malibu home burned down
in 2018 amid the california wildfires
and they lost everything so miley says
she clung to what i had left of that
house which was me
and him how cool is that to be wife
husband and wife
it's the best it's the best it's um you
know i feel so lucky to be with someone
like her and uh
yeah it's great very very very lucky the
pair married in december 2018
and split less than a year later in
august 2019.
the reason why miley says they had too
much conflict
quote when i come home i want to be
anchored by someone
i don't get off on drama or fighting but
still
miley insists i really do and did love
him
very very very much and still do always
will
it never goes exactly how i think it's
going to but somehow it always ends up
being better
now e.t is learning about liam's
reaction to miley's revealing
interview a source tells us that even
though liam was very hurt when they
initially broke up
he isn't upset about what miley said for
now he's focused on his new girlfriend
model gabriella brooks quote he's very
traditional and gabriella shares the
same values as him and gets along with
his family
their relationship is easy going and
they have similar upbringings and
backgrounds
i am everyone's happy i'm happy
[Applause]
[Music]